you decide to wear your wedding dress
from your previous engagement yeah how
were you able to keep your cool why did
it not bother you I don't know dress is
a dress in my opinion
depend call some
it's not what it meant for me yeah and
if it was her dream dress and her vision
of that's how she wanted to do it
why would I stand in the way of it
freaked out at me it was like kind of
crazy I'm kind of worried about you guys
that's how it's gonna be forever that's
really like a big deal your guys's
arguments give him cold feet it's so
good to see the two of y'all all loved
up all married now let me see you got
that ring on your face yes looking he's
losing it artem you know when I dance
sometimes just kind of like sliding in
I'm like you know what I'm just gonna
put in my bag when I dance when was the
official wedding day August 26th y'all
pulled this off in four weeks in four
weeks what were you thinking so I
thought it was a really smart idea
because you know in entertainment you
never know when you're gonna book a gig
and then we always pretty much know
artem's dates with Dancing with the
Stars and then we all of a sudden were
like wait Mateo's starting school and
you just start to think of all these
things and I'm like well when are we
ever gonna have time so there was this
perfect time we can do it and I thought
four weeks is easy Bree Loft I mean then
I kind of had felt like I kind of had a
point to improve but I will say I don't
suggest it after doing it are you
frustrated with yourself for putting
yourself under such time constraints now
like a hindsight even though I will say
there was something about it made me
very present and with like artem there
was a long wait time so I just felt like
you were it was kind of a fun journey I
finally decided that we're gonna get
married okay in like four weeks and what
well happy wife happy life
put that to use often if you had more
time what would you all have done
differently but then guest wise really
maybe my family yeah yeah my parents all
right that was a tough one yeah it was
nearly impossible it's same for you to
have your family present because of
what's going on between Russia and the
Ukraine right now were any of your
family members able to make it no but
they were tuning in with zoom which is
apparently nowadays it's like is the way
to go uh no they can travel they only
can travel to a few places in Europe and
unfortunately not one of them I'm so
sorry we had hope though till the very
end it was really amazing of
e-entertainment because they flew
someone to Russia to go help like can we
get visas passports how can we make this
happen and nothing like there was just
no we couldn't do anything not even to
get him in like few days and then they
travel back and everything was a no this
is what I say it wouldn't matter oh god
artem really I feel like the first
episode I'm like I'm really impressed
with the cool that you keep especially
with this aspect of things you decide to
wear your wedding dress from your
previous engagement yeah I have a
feeling that most guys most rooms would
not have kept their cool as you did
artems really I yes how were you able to
keep your cool why did it not bother you
that's why I'm married I don't know
dress is a dress in my opinion it
depends what it means cold it's not
working for me
um yeah and if it was her dream dress
and her vision of that's how she wanted
to do it why would I stand in the way of
it and I said I wouldn't like
like dress could be off the table if
there's yeah and she did awesome I mean
like directly it's like hey what do you
think of this yes I would say how to
that one likes it like oh you're gay you
can work but whatever no I actually
truly like it's yeah I'm totally okay
with it it was beautiful you saw it as
this is a reflection of you yeah not
some past guy right totally and that's
the thing is with wedding dresses so
much it's what the woman puts on and how
she feels and like you know her moment
and it's not I mean maybe some people
put their dress on and say he will love
this I didn't say that I was like this I
love it so beautiful I feel like a
princess and all the things and also I
paid for it so on top of it I was like
okay well I paid for the dress and I
wanted it and I just remember thinking
like that it's so unfair that like I
can't wear my dream dress because of
what people think and like that's when
all of a sudden I was thinking about
this I go no because and what is that
representing like now I'm not gonna do
that and I was like you know what I
might I may get dragged for it and I
know people gonna have their opinions
but at the end of the day you gotta do
you and at least I was a good fiance and
came to RM and if he had an issue with
it I knew like okay that's a year ago
but he was like so cool yeah and I even
had a talk with him off camera like are
you sure yeah you're not just being cool
right and he was like I really don't
care but artem's also all about saving
money too so I feel like he was like
please somebody's got it you can't both
be Big Spenders
wedding day something always goes wrong
but if you need a second
does everyone know the trauma that's
happening this is like a disaster just
had my groom ran away did you pull a
runway for a moment no you're just gonna
have to watch to see what happened it
has an explanation for everything yeah
but I loved it because he got he was all
drama and I just was so chill like but
I'm gonna let him have his moment I
don't know I need to see her because you
know you can't see
a lot of drama went down and everyone's
coming to me and I was like no you know
I'm not gonna let this affect me right
now so I just kept drinking my champagne
letting everyone handles stuff we'll
play and I remember they're like why
isn't she freaking out and I was like
you know I did this in four weeks and
it's the fan right now will so be it let
it hit yep I'm I'm in Paris France I'm
one of my favorite places in the world
and if this turns into a party and not a
wedding well then
I was very happy it was a wedding thank
goodness for a little DWTS yeah for
introducing the two honestly you know
who would have thought when I look back
at our interviews like during that time
period and I'm like if you were to tell
me this was going to be my husband and
my baby daddy like I'd be like yeah
right like I just and you know I mean
that in a great way right yeah no did
you feel that did you feel an instant
connection it was so this financial
story so once we get partnered up with
the partner we're kind of checking in
with the producers for
so I was calling back and I think that's
what I said to her I was like I didn't I
think I'm in love She's amazing can you
believe that and I didn't even set it in
the way like I'm in love like oh my God
like it was just kind of like flew out
of my mouth and I kind of didn't really
make anything of it when he told me that
story he didn't tell me that story for
like a while after we were even dating
and I was like what did you say because
I just I mean I learned when he first
met me I did my wrestling entrance and
like tore my Shroff chucked it in his
face and then they made me wrestle him
hi I'm Nikki arm Dragged In beat him up
a little bit in the turnbuckle and then
salsa and I was like all right there you
go
all right if my parents will never meet
my son that would be the most
devastating thing in there how did it
feel having Mateo be a part of your
special day he's everything he's the
most precious he's the biggest cuddler
he's just this bundle of joy that just
like can't get enough of it honestly he
is and we'll love like more than
anything with life like we would do
anything with this little kid yeah it
was special to have him part of that day
too and it definitely changes things
like how so you feel like I wanted to
play with him so much before Glam and
then I I mean poor Eileen was for like a
him we really need to claimer right but
like you just it's so about them and
it's like you want every moment with
them so I think some Brides have a
different day they're you know with
their bridesmaids they're having their
drinks and for me I was with my sister
but with Mateo so much of the morning
and we are just having so much fun
playing and then I didn't start climbing
until we went down for his nap like it
was still like a normal day for us but
like oh when you wake up where Mom and
Dad are getting married right so when
know we adding to the mix when is Mateo
getting a sip I'm just gonna say I'm not
the one carrying it for nine months so
it's not gonna be my choice and it's a
shame y'all can't
I would get pregnant tomorrow right to
be honest I would I feel like I'm in
truly in a place where I can be one and
done getting my career back because I
really wanted I think the one Blessing
about the pandemic for me is it forced
me to like stop and really think what I
wanted out of life but then spend time
with my son and now I have a hard time
ever leaving him and he's traveled so
much with us he's gone to set with me
he's gone to Dancing with the Stars and
he just loves being with Mom and Dada
like he wants to always be with us and
he goes everywhere with us and it's it
works out so perfectly yeah after seeing
Brian went to came into the mix I'm like
that looks tough changes everything
Amber he goes oh yeah she's like there's
no more traveling going to sets like
that and so artem and I talk about this
like right now we're in such an amazing
flow like I wish you know there could be
another one and we'll see I'm 39 maybe
in a few years I would love for Mateo to
have a sibling but he's also so close to
his cousins who are like siblings so I
mean literally he has almost a built-in
twin I mean he does
they act like brothers and they are so
close and so we'll see yeah the thing is
is like I didn't I didn't do tubes tied
well I didn't have I guess C-section but
I didn't do anything where it will
prevent me ever to be pregnant so
they're still working we will see
[Music]